dimitra who is the founder of jbm who
are an executive search and recruitment
firm who specialize in recruiting for
high-growth businesses and is also the
host of his own podcast called the 40
minute mentor james thank you for
joining me thanks for having me you so
much appreciate it yeah obviously we we
had this uh in the diary to do it face
to face in uh your office which is also
down the road from me and in london
bridge but
here we are today with a zoom mate how
things change yeah i know the world is a
very different place but um still still
honored to be on the show and uh
delighted to do it albeit virtually yeah
wicked so i think
what what my intention is with the sort
of podcast i record during the times of
what's going on is very much we're
definitely going to talk about your
business journey
how you go into recruitment um and so
what we always do here on the podcast
but we'll definitely have
a segment on talking about
how you're adapting today
um as a recruitment business owner um
but let's start where we always liked on
this podcast which is how did james
enter the world of recruitment let's
start there and and i don't think you'll
be surprised i i've listened to a few of
these episodes and um
probably like a lot of people i fell
into it
i think back in the day when i was a kid
there were aspirations to be a
professional
rugby player cricket player i was always
too small and not talented enough
i thought i'd be a broadcast journalist
like the idea of being on sky sports
news okay and again realized they didn't
get paid that much and it was quite
difficult and everyone else wanted to do
it yeah so so for me i never really knew
exactly what i wanted and i think i
didn't go to uni yeah i did i did a
history degree
okay
knew i didn't want to be a history
teacher or
work in a museum
love the degree love the uni experience
um i actually i worked for
i actually took a year off when i left
school um moved to london
three blokes in a one bed flat in east
london it was it was one bed yes wow
leave that to the imagination
was your near shoreditch though yeah no
not even that oh really hannah park and
we had
in our garden one night pretty pretty
rapey but
the character building stuff um but no i
am
i basically wasn't 100 sure what i
wanted to do but i knew i wanted to
leave home live in london save up go
traveling and actually that that first
year was was actually my first exposure
to recruitment because okay
i did uh i worked through i think it was
ranstad as a template bank in new york
um wow
amongst many other things i i i moon
well i've moonlighted in the past as a
singer i did some gigs i worked in what
worked at buckingham palace as a way so
i did all sorts that year and but i i
realized you know from the from the
experience of bank of new york and each
summer when i was at university i went
back to the bank
i had no real interest in going into
financial services
and when i kind of left when i graduated
um i was kicking around at home
and basically a mate of mine when i went
to rugby session rugby training session
pre-season
was a manager at michael page and and he
just sort of said look i think you'd be
i think you'd be a good recruiter and
you know it's it's it's not the it
wasn't the greatest time post recession
just the recession was what year was
that in 2009 oh wow okay
of he sort of said look i think you
should apply for the grad scheme
i thought i didn't know anything about
recruitment if i'm honest i just i'd go
along and you know use it as a interview
practice and yeah and i really enjoyed
the i really enjoyed the assessment
center it was um a bunch of similar
like-minded people
and it was role-playing i did a drama a
level so for me it was just like killed
you know yeah i think i've been alright
on the kind of mock role play bit and
yeah before i knew it i was i was one of
one of the first three people to be
hired post recession into the grad
interview
but it was um
it was a risky time they wouldn't they
didn't want to hire you full time you
had a month almost like a month rolling
really initially yeah and then i i
started off in technology and and then
quite quickly they realized i'd be
better suited to the consultancy test
the strategy and change recruitment sure
and that was kind of how how i ended up
there and the rest really is kind of
history okay
awesome really cool story so just to set
the scene then so you worked at michael
page i think i saw on linkedin is it
what two and a half years or three
two and a half years yeah and then after
that i don't think it was straight after
was it but a couple of months apart that
you then started your own recruitment
business which is now you've been
running for over seven years
yeah so
you're coming coming up to the decades
mark of uh
working in recruitment
um okay cool so look let's definitely
just talk a bit about
the sort of michael page experience
so i guess
how how did you find that how how
because obviously you must have been
someone that showed good promise put in
the work
very early on on a month by month basis
if they were sort of trying to protect
sort of their investment in offering you
sort of a monthly running contract right
so i guess that must have been quite
intense yeah to be honest with you they
they made
they cut one of the grants within a
month i think
the other two of us perm so it was it
was okay after that initial month or two
but um but yeah it was it was a it was
unlike anything i'd experienced before
um and i'll be honest i
i learned times i wouldn't be where i am
today if it wasn't for the training i
got there yeah you know the exposure i
had um i
i worked in a really small but very
talented team
and i had a brilliant but demanding boss
a guy called james barrett who's still
there
um and and it was kind of it was a
single swim really i think i
you know it was just at the time when
the recession was kind of we're at the
back end of it but it was still tough
um so you had to hustle um but because i
was recruiting a lot for management
consulting firms they were being roped
in to fix a lot of the issues in banks
and so i was there wasn't because there
was only three of us or four of us in
the team i just quite quickly had to get
in front of partners get in front of
senior clients really
and and so i had exposure to kind of
senior clients bigger yeah so would you
straight away 360 then basically was it
per more contract pretty much it was it
was all planned yeah
pretty much 360. i mean the bd stuff
came um but um but but i loved it i
loved i was allowed my style has always
been very consultative i love talking to
smart people about interesting stuff um
and i kind of i think i really revel
particularly with the client facing
stuff quite early on um and yeah my team
was brilliant and and really supported
me um i think
i realized i was very good at building
relationships
i
um i i really enjoyed the kind of
i guess i like the pressure i think um
that i kind of the competitive sportsman
with him was was kind of enjoyed that
target driven environment um and i had a
lot of luck you know
and in that first year but it went
pretty well
and and i guess set me up quite nicely
um so yeah it was i had a really good
first year
second year not so good if i'm honest
really yeah i think that's obviously you
know christian don't you christian james
that yeah i heard
it's very similar experience very voice
was you like the top of the leaderboard
then or what was going on in that team
near enough yeah i i had a very i had a
good first year in 2010 to my first full
year would you what did you build that
yeah 205k yeah first year that's not bad
i've had another gun in the past called
um
tom ennifer who i think he did um i'm
doing justice here but i think he did
like 250 or something in his first year
and that and he's been in recruitment
now for over five years and that's
that's been his best year today and
that's [ __ ] killing them
horrible you know you you set the
expectations really yeah because that's
obviously what christian shared is that
you've you've set the expectation as you
said so then second year sometimes when
things don't start going your way it can
be even more tough right yeah
and i'm not um
i've never been one to proclaim i'm like
the world's biggest builder for me it
was it was a combination of facts i
worked really really hard yeah longer as
a lot of my mates working in banking in
that first year and my boss was really
supportive and and we had roles you know
we had great clients that were hiring it
was yeah
it's it was very different a year before
that when there was nothing and you
really had to hit the phones and
you know um you know just try and hunt
work down and so that was lucky but the
second year was tough because my boss
changed you know i i really liked my my
new boss but very different working
styles um
i had to you know as you get more
experience you take more responsibility
on i wasn't the official manager but you
know working with with other people
grads were coming into the team getting
involved with recruitment of of staff
and
i i found i was being pulled in lots of
different directions sure and they still
had the expectations i'm assuming of
like
doing good numbers yeah totally that's
always the challenge isn't it and i can
never remember exactly what i did but it
was it was almost set and it was it was
hard i think half of the billings of the
year before yeah maybe less and and that
really i struggled with that and i think
you know listening to christian's
episode was really interesting because i
think i probably did get a little bit
complacent yeah
and
but if i'm honest my head head really
wasn't in it uh that was yeah
i was tired um i think in hindsight i
was probably quite stressed
the i found my style wasn't always
true you know completely appreciated i
think that ultimately there is still
that kpi culture it is true you know
and i think i i got increasingly
frustrated by that um and i hated you
know i was told consistently i couldn't
do bd
which is ironic now because it's easily
the best thing i don't think i'm best at
yeah but back then that got in my head
and i i hated the cold calling i hated
those sessions where you just got
printed
contacts just to get in touch with it
wasn't for me like i i would try and get
out of training sessions yeah yeah or
sickies you know i i really i really
wasn't in the best place and it's only
in hindsight i realized that um but you
know i had some family yeah i had some
family illness going on at the time and
i think i just head was a bit scrambled
sure you really when uh my i got my my
now wife uh my uh at the time girlfriend
i got her
introduced her to paige she did six
months i can't say she loved it but
the the the start of our relationship
and
she's known me since school so we grew
up together and i think one of the
turning points for me was when she just
was like you are not you're not yourself
and why but when she saw you in that
business and stuff yeah oh wow i was
powerful i was stressed and you know
always had the sunday night blues and
and ultimately and this is probably
something we'll touch upon again i
really struggled to buy into that big
corporate yeah um really really
struggled with that and and i think
ultimately that is where kind of i think
i drifted
checked out mentally and it was really
when i broke my leg playing rugby that i
was forced you know to sort of step away
from the day-to-day grind have my leg in
a cast and it was in you know at home
for
four four to six weeks it was then when
i just went you know what like life is
too short yeah you need to change it and
i basically handed him my notice and
you know took the plunge and and started
started looking for something else but
at that time
i was basically like i don't want to
work in this industry i'm done okay this
is ironic
yeah yeah so
we'll definitely go into that but what i
just want to touch on
is just um two things there which i i'd
like to think people will benefit from
so the first thing just as you were
talking about there i feel like
there would be a lot of people that
maybe resonate with that they may feel
like um they have the sunday blues or
they might have been mentally they might
mentally checked out their recruitment
job or whatever and find it really
difficult or have been
but i think it's interesting isn't it
because like i think there'll be so many
stories out there that it takes the sort
of dramatic event of you breaking your
leg to be like james what the [ __ ] you
doing
do you know what i mean but i think
sometimes those events don't happen for
people and it unfortunately happens with
people when they're three years down the
line they look back and they're like wow
i actually regret not making that
decision or whatever right so i guess
obviously hindsight is a great thing but
how do you think or what sort of comes
to mind for you if people are sort of in
that mental space of you know what i
don't think i'm enjoying this blah blah
blah what would your advice be to those
people to try and
move that event or encourage people to
look in the mirror and try and cultivate
them to make that decision themselves
like what comes up for you with that
well
so firstly i i think things like your
show to honestly is is a really useful
tool for you because nothing like this
existed you know when i was there that
you know it and i think what people are
now they have access to stories from
people that have been there and done it
and yeah and i think one of the first
things i would say is that you really
need to look inside and work out if you
actually want to do this job because it
isn't for everyone i think a lot of
people just get their head down maybe
it's the money trap maybe it's the i
don't know maybe it's stability but
unfortunately there's a lot of people in
this industry that just keep plugging
away that i just don't think it's the
right thing for them yeah um but i also
think there's also a lot of great
recruiters to get very disillusioned
because they're in the wrong company
and they don't buy into the mission and
they don't you know they're not and i
think that is absolutely critical for me
for instance i would struggle to recruit
probably anything else i love the area
of the i love working with startups and
scale-ups i love working in strategy and
operations i would really struggle to
get motivated to recruit others other
sectors so that's just me um and and i
have to buy into the mission of a
business so one thing i would say is
sometimes it needs external influence to
help you see that and that's why i would
and not to plug my 40-minute mental
podcast but mentorship is so important
yeah
you know get a mentor get someone that's
maybe outside the industry or even
someone from within it that can actually
give you objective advice and ultimately
call you out
and tell it to you straight because
there's no point having a mentor unless
they're going to be super honest with
you sometimes you just need to have that
candid chat with someone about how
you're feeling and i think there's tons
now that i think it's becoming that
we all have mental health and i think um
it's becoming less of a
hopefully the stigma is being broken
down a little bit talking to people
being honest about how you're feeling
and actually sort of forcing yourself to
look within if you're not yourself and
if you're struggling and if you have
those sunday nights the great thing
about the environment today is there are
so many things you can do to change it
you know reach out to businesses that
you're inspired by you can you can
listen to podcasts like yours and and
hear of different ways to do the job and
ultimately when you've been in
recruitment for a while and you have
those skills
they are very transferable yeah yeah
yeah totally that's terrible yeah
yeah when i look at our client base and
one of the most popular most sought
after skills is sales and account
yeah that's what comes up for me to be
fair i think yeah i think yeah i love
how you sort of spoke about i guess yeah
the first thing is
yeah be be honest with yourself um
in terms of are you enjoying it what
parts do you enjoy that you don't enjoy
is it the market or whatever and then
also yeah as you said don't
definitely don't um
underestimate how valuable your skill
set is that you land on recruitment i've
definitely experienced that firsthand
the sort of journey that i've been on
and then also yeah i think
that that's the great thing about sort
of the environment we're in now is that
don't sort of be under the illusion that
recruitment is how it is in your
business everywhere and how it's done or
whatever so
okay cool and then the other thing i
wanted to ask you because obviously you
clearly spoke and this is quite common
in big businesses people get access to
great people quite quickly but
looking back why why was that manager um
why did that manager have such an impact
on you do you think um
he was tough he was really he had he had
very very high expectations sure and he
would and and i'm not this sort of
manager so so i i um
it's interesting isn't it the the type
of managers you respond to but it
doesn't always mean that's going to be
you
know
at times maybe i think i should have
been more like him but and he so he
effectively he had really high standards
yeah you know he would put me on the
spot with things what does that mean
like and it it was it was a style that
didn't work for a lot of people yeah
he's been super successful and he he
ultimately had my back as well that he
supported me you know when there was
some i had some sort of family illness
going on he was incredible i remember
him taking me out for dinner once and i
was really struggling with a family
member being unwell and he took me out
for dinner he just listened and talked
and supported me so awesome i always he
had my back and i had his and he was
also very very good at the job so i
learned times going to client meetings
with him he's the first person i worked
with it you know and actually a couple
of others in my team who the client
genuinely listened to what they said
they they were experts in what they did
and i took tons from that and i actually
like i liked the way he challenged me
because it forced me to raise my game
yeah i'm kind of the the main the maybe
yeah yeah i like that cool so
you broke your leg playing rugby
robbie careers out out the window
um so obviously yeah a couple of months
i'm assuming reflecting which i'm sure a
lot of people now are in that position
obviously haven't broken their leg but
on furlough
and yeah generally i think it's going to
be interesting i think obviously with
what's going on now i think a lot of
people
are
i've personally if you
what am i trying to say like if you're
not really clear on why doing what
you're doing what your purpose is i
think a lot of people are going to have
a lot of time to think about that and so
where their career is going these types
of things you know but i'm sure
opportunity mate yeah yeah exactly so i
think obviously um
obviously when when you experience that
i'm sure that you're in in your house
flat whatever
um
legging the cast you're like okay what
the hell am i gonna do right so see that
led you to hand in your notice so did
you did you and at that point you said
that you was considering not working or
remaining in the industry so what talk
to me about the thought process of you
leading up to starting your own
recruitment business well i was i was i
was lucky in some ways because i knew at
that time given that the dynamic of our
team that michael they needed me
as much as i needed them in some ways so
i was able to have it and they were very
very good with me i said to them look
i'm not going to do this long term yeah
i don't can go to another recruitment
firm i want to hand in my notice and but
i will stay until i found something
until we found a replacement for me so
it was a it was good in that respect and
they gave me the time to go interview
and it's not always said about life
but that was that was really helpful and
i think you know hopefully i went about
it in the right way
and and i tried different things i i
interviewed for a sport to be a rugby
agent i uh i interviewed for a sales
role in a professional services firm and
i ended up basically going to to work
for a former client that had set up a
management consultancy so i'd been
recruiting for consultancies yeah and
this was a startup uh business
and and they'd heard it was actually her
and her husband had heard that i was
looking for a change and they wanted
someone young and entrepreneurial
relatively cheap and who
who wanted to help when it comes to
business development and so basically i
joined to help
leverage my network to help them sell
consulting solutions and it was
completely the opposite it was kind of i
was given a credit card an ipad which at
the time was like incredible
one of those ones that now is probably
the size of my laptop
and but yeah and then it was like go
winner some business um
and it was i was completely out of my
depth
and
yeah and frankly realized very very
quickly that selling people and selling
in people to roles is completely
different to selling consulting
solutions can you imagine and and you
know i learned tons but i didn't set the
world a lie and it was really only kind
of i enjoyed the staffing of the project
piece i enjoyed learning from great
entrepreneurs because they were
but i found it lonely and i found it um
i just found it difficult and i think it
was only about nine months in where it
was a summer there wasn't much to do
a few of my old clients been
consistently reaching out to me saying i
don't suppose you can help with that xyz
and i said well to the to the partners i
said look do you want me to just set up
a recruitment business on the side you
just uh you know i think there's some
money that could be made here i wanted
to prove myself because i haven't yeah
with the others
and yeah and i kind of yeah i picked a
couple of clients generated about 30k
for them that in in a month and was like
that was kind of the light bulb moments
like yeah
well if if i can do this and all these
clients of mine all these candidates of
mine is doing it in my own style and i
don't hate it perhaps maybe i just need
to go and take the plunge and and do it
on my own and they were very
understanding
but that's basically the genesis of jbm
it kind of i was 25
and i
the thing i loved from that experience
was the entrepreneurialism yeah i just
sort of thought like i'm sure lots of
people listening would have had this
like i i was and i feel embarrassed to
say this now but i was ashamed at times
about being a recruiter yeah and they're
going to parties and
you know dinners and stuff and and
people ask me what i did and you're
rolling their eyes and going oh yeah
yeah
person not that there's anything wrong
with the state agents and but i i
remember at times just thinking well and
it was that kind of mayweather i was
like well do you know what unless i do
something about that you know i'm not
like everyone else i never have been
i've always been my own person i've got
my own style my way of doing things and
i thought well actually if i if i set up
a business on my own do it in my own
style in my own sort of with my own
values maybe i'll start to change some
of those hearts and minds yeah
but also i've got nothing to lose i love
a challenge and when i started talking
to people about it there were lots of
people saying you're not it's not going
to work you're 25 you've only been doing
recruitment for two years you know good
luck but i was gonna say how did how did
you overcome that because i think
yeah i think a lot of people would have
that um
imposter syndrome and and let that let
that voice i i certainly had
that uh conversation myself when i sort
of started my
business ten months ago
um yeah just turned 27 so similar sort
of ages and i very
i always tell people i definitely had
the conversation of hisham who are you
to start a business like this or help
people with this you haven't you've only
been doing it for how many years
whatever so yeah i'll totally resonate
with that but i feel like a lot of
people will feel like that so how did
you um block out that noise
uh i've always liked the challenge uh
yeah for me and i think this this
probably says a lot about one's
entrepreneurial ability or
whether it's right for you because for
me that that was the fire in the bed i
wanted to prove people wrong you know
and that it didn't it didn't i didn't
whereas there were definitely lots of
times i've had imposter syndrome over
the last few years but actually
interestingly at that point i was like
nah i'm going to go for this and you
know
there are some other really important
factors here like i
i didn't have tons to lose it's not like
i had a mortgage yeah my girlfriend
lucinda who's now my wife was incredibly
supportive like she's always has been
she's awesome believed in me and she was
like you can do like go for it
and and probably the other really
important thing is i did run this
concept past clients and candidates
and they basically said look your style
is what this industry needs like we will
back you we will work with you and and
that kind of gave you that instilled
confidence
yeah absolutely so
yeah so yeah so i was just going to say
it so
how did you how did you plan to be
different then because i think this is i
think obviously what you're talking
about there's sort of changing the sort
of perception of recruitment in your
market and these types of things like
what what was the strategy behind jbm to
be different because i think that's all
that a lot of this recruitment
businesses start with that intention
don't know that i wanna do it my way and
this is what you're talking about so
what was your thought process to the
sort of business strategy and how how
did you plan to be different when you
started it
yeah i mean
every every recruitment company says the
same right
but but for me i guess i wanted to prove
it so
when i when i was i remember
writing down some words about what i
want to be named for at the time
the values or the the characteristics
were i wanted to be seen as like an
honest consultative very relationship
driven recruiter yeah i was like well
how do i prove that and ultimately it's
just through delivering great service
like
and the proofs in the pudding so for me
it was just about in those early days it
was about hustling
getting opportunity
delivering like going above and beyond
and then letting the work do the talking
so jbm has grown exclusively through
word of mouth in terms of business
development every single client we've
ever won okay i may have gone oh i
really want to work with that company
and i and spoken to someone and they put
me in touch but it's all come through
somebody recommending us awesome and i
set out like that was for me was always
going to be the benchmark and like how
we you know we grew um
and ultimately i think yeah it was about
proving that early doors and so i kind
of um i sort of said that's kind of how
i set out and just like that's what i'm
going to be known for
i obviously knew the sector i wasn't
trying to do something totally different
yeah yeah i've recruited covenant
covenant's obviously been finished by
then so
it was yeah mainly finally got more
experience by actually working in the
industry as well so adds to the story
exactly and that was exactly it i
initially started by saying i want to go
work with startup consultancies because
i just come from one so that's how i
started it was a good story because i
was saying look i understand the pain
points because i've been in one i've
been
as a client and and i want to you know i
was ultimately saying to clients i want
to be a partner i do not want to be a
transactional recruiter if you want me
alongside five other agencies that's
fine but that's not going to be really
what i'm looking for i want to help your
business grow alongside my business and
i was saying look what i also really
care about is getting it right for the
long term so for me it was always about
understanding the values of the business
understanding what makes it tick and
then ultimately and getting to spending
the time to get to know my clients
better than most yeah awesome and then
delivering on that by finding the right
culture of it not always the right cv
and i think i've always been trying to
be quite late with my thinking around
fit and i think
there's not always been a science to it
but a feeling sometimes and um and i i
guess i tended to get that right in the
early days and that really helped how
was your first year then how did it go
uh first it was pretty good and was it
just year that was just yeah yeah it's
last two years so guys and was that
always the plan like what what did you
even think about this being a lifestyle
business or growing the business the
really interesting question if i'm
honest when i started i had no idea yeah
no idea what i wanted do you think
that's okay
i i think so yeah
the sort of person you are because for
me
if i'm if i'm if i'm truly honest i
i i wanted to i just want to start a
business and i wanted to see if it could
work but i purposefully kept under the
radar we had for two years we had no
website no data really no nothing yeah
it was no database all people out of
mouth everything on excel not the best
way to do it
i should have set that up earlier
it was all through word of mouth and
part of that and it's only on reflection
i i was also worried about it failing so
i didn't want really not to know
that i'd set up on my own so everything
was done under the cloak of darkness wow
and but it was it was also
if i if if i think about it now
i wasn't sure where it was going to go
yeah i also had some some financial guys
so i am not money motivated um i never
really have been and but what i decided
was actually a really good way of kind
of giving myself some targets was um was
thinking about it i wanted to marry my
girlfriend um we went to school together
so as soon as we even though we were
young and i knew as it was it was it
once we got together because yeah all
our friends are the same our families
know each other you know there was no
going back and i'm punching so i needed
to
so for me that was the first financial
goal before the ring second one was
paid for the wedding uh with some
support from from our families and third
one was have like a dream honeymoon that
we'd never normally go for but like you
know basically go for it and then
finally it was to get on the property
ladder and
basically over the course of those two
years i ticked those off and awesome it
was only at the end of that i was like
oh [ __ ] i've got business here there was
actually a business and it was
when i actually would say i started to
properly build jbm but yeah so that so
that's kind of how it all began and like
that first first few months were
hustle and challenging and i almost ran
out of money at month four i had to
borrow some money would you spend the
money on if you didn't have a database
didn't have a website well this is why i
say you don't need much to set up a
video you probably need a bit more now
than you did but and because i i
literally phone uh i
i did a really really
no offense to my mate but
pretty crap logos
and then
it was just coffees i was going coffee
shop to coffee shop around really just
just trying my luck and then i think i
and and to honestly my mate my mate tim
who comes back into this story he became
my business partner he worked for me at
michael page he went to a startup and he
got me in to do some some some
recruitment for them in-house for like a
couple of months and that was recruiting
chefs and waiters and all sorts but it
was just trying to keep the cash flow
going um
but i you know it ended up it ended up
going really well and that first year
that the kind of changing point for me
was when i realized if i kept working
with startups i was going to run out of
money and i almost did at that kind of
four month mark and why is that
because it was just
the fees were relatively low
like my first
my first fee was 5k i think i made the
first three placements came to about 15
grand yeah it was was was great like you
know when you when you're when you're
starting your own but it was just like
that's not going to keep you going yeah
yeah
and and basically i i i
how quickly did it take to make your
first placement then
about three months oh really okay yeah
about two or two and a half about two
and a half months yeah yeah
and and but then it was kind of three in
quick relatively quick succession but
the the game changer was when i went i
went down to meet a candidate
ex-candidate at one of the big banks
and he we were just talking about how he
was going and he was he was using a top
exact search for him for his co uh yeah
they were offering business and we were
chatting about it and i just said all
right it sounds like you need an ex
management consultant and and he was
like oh okay yeah i was like you know
they can face off to the regulator they
can drive change they can shape strategy
and he was like oh do you know some of
them and i was like yeah
and then and basically i just blagged my
way onto this clo search for this big
bank never done cla recruitment before
but it kind of felt like a good
extension and i'd gone from just having
to these small little clients suddenly
tier one bank
and that that was a 35 grand fee that
i've when i filled it and that was kind
of like game changer breathing room i
could then say i'd work with this bank
and that was that was when i started
that year to then you know start
reaching out to my old contacts at bcg
deloitte ey santander et cetera and that
kind of that's when it started to take a
bit of momentum so yeah long-winded way
of coming back to your original question
yeah yeah it was i think we did about
186k
in year one yes that's not bad is it
just you
no website no database and i didn't even
know it was yeah i know i'm not your you
know i've heard some stories from some
of the guys i'm not like a lot of other
i wasn't like loved it wasn't like oh my
god i want to set the world light i was
just
you know it was those small financial
well i'm not small but those for me i
had those yeah
and then i was just enjoying running my
own thing but i had no life i i didn't
see any of my mates for a year and
really it was long long days and you
know pretty pretty hard work at times
but um but it was good fun so so just a
quick one on that to wrap up sort of
year one then knowing what you know now
what would your advice be to people that
yeah have really been thinking about
starting their own recruitment business
i think it's the first year that people
are most worried about
how it's actually going to go if they're
going to end up like you said recruiting
chefs when they really they want to do
something else or whatever so
like
yeah what would you how what would you
say to those people
i mean if if you're good at the job like
if you have the recruitment skills and
most importantly if you have
if you're great at building
relationships and you look at things
from a longer term perspective then i
would say like
as long as you've got that risk appetite
i would always go for it and i think
you know i think when you when you make
that step changing you you really commit
to it you just have to accept that it's
going to be hard work it's going to be
there's going to be awful days and when
it's your when it's your baby those
highs are amazing and those lows are
like killer yeah
it's yeah it's it you take things very
personally particularly oh yeah 100
and so i think for me it's about
one
you know you need to be known for
something you've got to have this you've
got to be a specialist in something
these days i think you've got yeah so
niche is important niche is important i
think you've got to be able to you know
you've got to have relationships i i'm
not i'm not one of those people that
could just set up something from cold
like and fair play to those that do but
for me i think you've got to have
relationships that trust you and will go
with you um or or if not at least know
this space well enough to know who to go
after yeah and then for me if i'm honest
it's about
working hard hustling being creative and
adding value and and and in this day and
age building your personal brand
and your company's brand pretty quickly
so it's clear why amongst all the noise
and all the other competitors out there
why people should work with you and i
still think there is a huge opportunity
for
values-driven honest you know
down-to-earth people that have someone
about them in this industry i think
there is a huge opportunity still yeah
why did it take the two-year mark for
you to think that you've got a real
business thing because i think a lot of
people would go i hung them in it
like 100 i'm just under 200 grand in
your first year like why was why yeah
why did it take that extra year for you
to go you know what i'm happy with what
i'm doing here like i think because i
didn't know what i was building
initially yeah and but but the breaking
point was i wanted to go on honeymoon so
i kind of um i got to support i was like
oh my goodness i'm going to be closing
deals my wife's going to divorce before
before i get back because i'm gonna have
to work through this
and and i was getting a bit lonely if
i'm honest it was uh it was tough um and
you know we do you not have anyone to
speak to
i did but because like mate so because i
set up jbm
relatively early
in my life i knew a lot of people that
had done you know i went down to meet
james khan's lot and all that and
there were people like that who were
incredible entrepreneurs made their
millions and there were people that i
knew that had failed yeah very few
people within five years of me that i
knew i'm sure they were out there yeah
yeah there weren't many people that i
could actually go
how do i do this well and that's why i
absolutely love mentoring and yeah
mothers to uh to set up on their own um
because i felt like i missed that a lot
so i did have i had great mentors my
uncle was this huge sounding board for
me during that time also my old bosses
at michael bay were great but um but
yeah that for me the big thing was i
just i wanted people around me i'm a
people person yeah yeah i totally get
that and it all it was all very
fortuitous because um one of my really
one of my best mates uh shawandi he was
in kind of a he was he was a lawyer and
and he had taken a career but he'd kind
of become disillusioned with the legal
industry a bit uh it took some time he
went snowboarding and he came back to
stay with me afterwards and we were
talking about you know he's a super
smart guy
had all the qualities to be an amazing
recruiter and and he was like i'm
looking to just you know i love love
working with clients and stakeholders
you know yeah got this entrepreneurial
itch i was like dude i'm going on
honeymoon two weeks like how do you
fancy follow me around for the next next
sort of fortnight and learning the ropes
and then would you be up for kind of
taking the reins and that's basically
how jk made their first hire it was one
of my favorites lawyer never worked in
recruitment and hats off to show andy he
he he came in it was
as i said nowhere no no website no
database completely unstructured um and
uh and he had to kind of pick up the
reins and he he did an amazing job i
mean he he was with me for a year he
then went in-house because he really
needed some like stability and like
proper grounding and he's gone on to
have a super successful career in
in-house legal recruitment and um
yeah so that he was number one hire and
then when i came back from honeymoon
tim and
came on board who was that's michael
page and very good friend he worked for
you as well yeah and he was the that was
the game-changing moment because
tim was really good at a lot of things
that i i'm not uh you know
infrastructure stuff project management
people management like he loves all that
and he was he came on board with
shawandi and it was like right tim's
gonna put in place our database uh he's
gonna help with hiring he's gonna yeah
you know take a load of other stuff you
know take on on the finances and and
that was kind of it was that point and
then for the next sort of few years
where we went on a steady but gross
growth trajectory and i think at the
time
we the intention was let's scale and
exit let's try and sell this thing that
was the intention
it was at the time before you weren't
money motivated mate well
it was it was more than right like yeah
yeah
you make a good point um but and this is
this is actually really important
because ultimately i don't think i ever
wanted to do that but for whatever
reason i went i went along with it
because yeah and it wasn't anyone else's
fault it was completely wrong but um i
don't think that was ever what i wanted
because that just doesn't really get
that's not really in my nature and so um
yeah so the next okay we're hiring
growing so let's let's just frame that
then so yeah year two then obviously tim
joined just after year two or whatever
and then so obviously then we're coming
up to the next sort of five years so
so if we were to break that down the
sort of first two and a bit years of tim
being involved was that then when yeah
ultimately you were getting the things
in obviously infrastructure in place
looking at growing the business
but but just quickly
how
how important would you say it is for
people to
um
really think about starting a
recruitment business with other people
like you've done always on your own i'm
didn't start a business on my own what i
do
i think it's got to be on the individual
yeah yeah i personally
there's huge benefit for doing it on
your own you make mistakes you're doing
it on your own time and money yeah i
always feel a huge responsibility for
others and um you know i've always said
jbm's a family so once you're in the
family like it's you know i take that
very seriously and in some ways
you need to make your mistakes on your
own time it might be yeah yeah that said
you can if you're if your intentions are
to scale um and build up you know then i
think there's huge value from um from
partnering up you look at the the three
search cards which i don't know well but
um you know andy i've met a few times in
their ex page and
what they've been able to achieve
is so impressive and i think probably
you know right who's that sorry did you
say three search research yeah yeah part
of like 11 investments obviously you
know joe over there um i don't actually
know joe but um they're they're kind of
sort of contemporaries of mine yeah sure
but like you see what three guys can do
yeah
you can really
you know escalate and accelerate growth
so for me personally i'm really glad i
did it the way i did
but um but i can totally see how having
someone to bounce ideas off and and kind
of take on things earlier can can
accelerate and accelerate yeah so how
how did you how did you plan to to grow
this business then
what was the plan yeah i mean
the plan was effectively to
to kind of launch into new areas so we
at the time we were doing financial
services strategy and changes mainly
clients and banks
um we ended up so within a year of that
so year three we were five
um we were hiring grads sort of someone
with one year's recruitment and
initially sort of through our networks
and then we kind of we got a bigger
office we got bullhorn we got q19 we
kind of started to make some bigger
investments yeah
you know and and i think
you know we
the way we were going to grow was we
launched an insurance business
so went into a new area that we know had
a guy called jimmy who was
was a great recruiter and had a really
good networks in that space
and and that was kind of how we were
going to go we were going to hire in
kind of we were going to have sort of
three directors and then hiring sort of
grads and bring them up through the
ranks yeah
and it was a real it was a real mixed
bag you know we had
we had to make them the vast majority of
people had were brilliant like
culturally great fits
added a lot of value um but the truth is
not all of them made the money and and
and i think probably we we made we made
a few mistakes um but we had in those
kind of those great years we had quite a
lot of success you know we we we did our
first international placement in 2016.
we um you know we set up a really i
think a really inspiring set of board of
advisors
and you know we hired alice who's he's
still with jbm he's a fantastic
recruiter in 2017 and you know so we had
lots of there was lots of good
and we had what i think was a unique and
a really really good culture
and and i guess tim was doing a really
good job of hiring and developing the
team and i was focusing more on building
out the exact search side and business
development but but yeah it kind of our
overheads went up considerably um and
you know we got to a point uh sort of a
couple of years ago when i think we were
having to complement we were growing
we'd grown to about six seven
and we were starting to compromise in
terms of the types of clients we were
working with lots more bigger corporates
less control um and frankly we were
still a bit too reliant on on my
billings um and my networks and not
everyone was it just wasn't quite
working and it was a really
challenging period
what were the mistakes during that then
because i think the this is this is if
i'm like the messages i get a lot from
particular recruitment business owners
is very much
it's just the most ironic thing isn't it
the the mistakes that you make and the
most challenging part is is getting the
people right for your own business when
you're in the business of getting people
for
other businesses do you know what i mean
so like what are some of the sort of key
mistakes you think that people can learn
from that you can obviously have the
benefit of of hindsight
yeah i mean
when it comes to hiring i think it still
is the most difficult thing for
recruiters to get right for themselves
which is as you said completely
ridiculous and i wrote
but again i think when it's your
business um you feel so invested and i
think the mistakes that we made and that
i hope people can learn from you know we
we we hired on culture fit
a lot um and i think we had some great
people that weren't necessarily always
right for our business or ourselves and
and that was really hard to take because
you know more often than not we really
like them and yeah you really like them
yeah
and i think i wouldn't change the fact
that i hop the first few highs were
friends because in those early days
um having that trust that dependable
really helped yeah and it really really
helped and we had a lot of fun um but
there was also a time when that we
needed to part ways and that that that
came about
um
and i think there's something to be said
for um having a rigorous interview
process you know
there were times when we were growing we
were so busy and doing really i guess to
the outside while doing really really
well like doubling our revenues and you
know it and that happened for a few
years but actually our costs were going
up
considerably and and i don't think we
always had the rigor to our process and
so now
i get my board of advisors involved with
interviewing um we make especially
senior candidates present a case study
or like a business plan
you know extensive referencing um i
think that it's so important to get
right
so
for me
having that process is worth it even
though you want to move at pace i think
you don't want to rush that you want to
you want to get it right um
yeah and i think
the other thing i'd say is that we we
hired a lot of people who were
disillusioned with recruitment a bit
like i was um and in some instances
it's just it's the end of the road like
if you really don't like recruitment and
you're done with it i think there are
times maybe when we should have realized
that sooner yeah whatever we did wasn't
going to change it whereas there have
been other instances when you've
actually really you've been able to help
them feel more valued you've given them
the things they weren't getting in the
other organization
and then and and actually turn it on its
head so this is what i said to a lot of
people and yes we're not we're not
saving lives here um we're not it's not
we're not a rocket scientist but you can
change lives yeah from doing what we do
and i think it's if you can if you can
see it like that and really feel like
okay i can help this person get the
property out i can give them back time
with their family i can i can really
have an impact in someone's life it can
totally change your perspective on how
you do the job and that's kind of what
we try to focus on now seeing the people
that get that see that and really that
can come out in the way that they do
do business
what was the best investment you made
tools wise do you think if you were
increasing overheads and
you know that what would you what's had
a really good impact on your business
um i think
oh that's a really good question and i
think cube19 has been been a good good
investment for us
that might help now right having
visibility on yeah but it's not it's not
in the way that maybe others would uh
maybe use it i think obviously gamified
recruitment and and we did for a while
have it up on the screen like yeah you
know sky sports but our culture and our
business is really not kpi driven at all
um and actually
one of the things we tried to create is
a culture where people can
say how they're feeling and sure it got
to appointments like they didn't really
actually necessarily want to see that
everywhere
but what is good is for driving the
right behaviors in terms of people
managing themselves and obviously we can
all see what everyone's doing like it's
there and you can look at your own one
and you can use that to drive
performance but from
an owner's perspective
having that data and insight is really
helpful to kind of get a sense of what's
what so that that for me is a really
good tool
okay nice and um just just to frame this
up then before we go into sort of
the last couple of years because i think
obviously that moment where you sort of
had those realizations were actually
maybe um obviously when we spoke before
this where you had to basically decide
we were talking about that become a bit
difficult looking at the team maybe
having to obviously um make that a bit
more lean or whatever but
like up until that point you were
talking about that led up to in terms of
hiring and things like that like where's
where was your revenue wise as a
business because obviously as you said
your overheads were going up yeah
yeah how were you there as a business i
think in terms of bra and i'm i'm pretty
terrible with numbers but okay you know
in terms of like turnover we were like
1.1 i think in 2016 2017 we did about
1.1 million
um uh you know i think our perm revenues
were probably it's kind of about 50 we
did about
i think in 2018 about 500 roughly about
500 k per yeah um and then we had a
decent temp book and but what we were
finding was we were we were just our
costs have gone up massively yeah yeah
and and and it was it was a it was it
was really when a couple of quarters
i think back end of 2018 we had two
clients to basically went under an oda's
40k
yeah we we were like it was getting
close to christmas and we literally
almost run out of money and now this is
this business has been totally
bootstrapped like there's never been any
investment it's just yeah we've done it
on our own and that was for me a really
you know i have a daughter and a wife
and a big mortgage and and that was a
really stressful time and we
you know we did what we had to do to get
through we didn't even go into the
overdraft but that was really stressful
and then then about six months later we
found ourselves in a similar situation
we made like a 65k loss in one quarter
wow and and it was just like we aren't
you know we had a board meeting and we
were very lucky to have a guy called
fred jones on our board he's actually
runs uber in the uk and he's he's on the
ball of uber here and amazing how the
hell do you manage that he's a candidate
of mine yeah really
yeah and he's so when you so when you
say just out of interest so like because
i think i had a lot of conversations
where smaller businesses
would love or want the opportunity to
work with like a non-exec right for
their business so
i guess having these people involved in
your board and when you say i have an
amazing board i'm assuming is it that
type of relationship where ultimately
you get in a room and then there's an
honest relationship with everyone
involved or is there a lot of commercial
interest for these people in your
business or what's the
and how valuable has that been yeah it's
one of the best things i've ever done
and it's something that any recruitment
owner that
i think that doesn't have one i'd
strongly suggest doing it and i think no
there is no commercial interest and i
mean it could be on the table but
basically the people that i've chosen
are friends okay they're also brilliant
at what they do and they all bring
something slightly different so we have
my
one of the people that trained me at
michael page she
used to run hudson in the uk after page
it's called stupakkum
he's one of our boards we've got an ex
candidate of mine who is a ceo at hsbc
former partner in the consultancy so she
brings the consulting banking
experience we've got um fred who brings
the scale-up experience and he's a
consultant he's account ex-candidate and
then we've got cressie who's the wild
card but she's a sustainability
entrepreneur business owner like
easily one of the most inspirational
people i have ever met and she brings a
completely fresh perspective yeah we
all is once a quarter i take them for
their payment is we go out for a nice
dinner um but we basically spent two
hours just
chewing the fat and i you know they're
very honest with me i'm very honest with
them about where our challenges are
where i could do with some some insights
and they're always at the end of the
phone and it's been incredible and it
was basically this point where we
actually had a separate session with
pratt a strategy session because we were
in trouble
and we we did we went we were there for
four hours and you gave so much time and
it was me tim and jimmy so the
management team in the business at the
time
and we did loads of analysis and he he
looked at it and he just like looked
guys you're look at the cv sent to all
these clients and the revenue
you've got a certain chunk and they're
typically smaller boutique businesses
who are paying you properly who value
your time yeah and there's all these
others who are just not and you know it
and it became so it just needed someone
to say it like we need to stop working
with corporate businesses we're just
like your style isn't fit suited to it
they don't appreciate the value yeah and
then the other side of it was looking at
our crossbass and looking at our our
staff and actually realizing well
they're not you know unfortunately we're
going to have to make some cuts here
because people are just not billing
enough and so yeah we basically it was
it was a lot of soul-searching it was a
very stressful
few days but as a management team we we
decided to restructure
tim and jimmy you know
did did an amazing thing and they said
look you know we
as a manager team you know expensive
resources um tim the plan had always
been in time for him to move in-house um
and he he said right let's let i think
it's now is the right time um jimmy
and you know we thought about do we
carry on as a two and he ultimately
thought well this is a good time for me
to take some time out i'm sorry
and then we sadly had to let let two of
the team go and it was a really it was
really stressful because again you know
damien's a family and to the outside
well nothing has changed we've still
delivered for our clients we're still
doing really well but internally and
financially it was proven challenging
and and i think i
personally didn't realize it but was
incredibly stressed yeah i wasn't
maximizing my own potential i was you
know not seeing my family i was working
harder than ever and there were lots of
things that kind of came out of it and i
i basically had to go to allison perry
at the time look i know this isn't what
you signed up for but this is kind of
what i'm thinking and i think
we this could actually be the making of
us and i think you know i just sort of
told them my new vision for the business
and it was so nice that they turned
around and were like we're totally on
board let's do this and yeah and yeah
and it
the next day i you know cut ties with
all our corporate clients very politely
and
we got straight to work on rebranding uh
the website we
we kind of rebranded just to focus on
high growth businesses and yeah
launched the podcast within a few months
we
started doing events we started being
punctured on fees and selling much more
retained and exclusive work
and critically you know we also claimed
our lives back um you know we cut the
costs in half over a course of six
months
um and
we had our you know we were i guess the
decision was vindicated quite quickly
because we had our record quarter that
next quarter between the vision
and so that was yeah that was it that
was really like a really good moment
yeah so
let's definitely segue into because i'm
sure that that's obviously had a massive
impact on how you guys are surviving
right now right with what's going on but
just very quickly i think there's so
much value in there and this has come up
actually before
um with a chap called um
tony bates and
they did this exercise where they cut
loads of clients and just and just
worked out that again the same sort of
process that you went through but just
to cut that down then for people just to
make that really clear so recruiters
listening or business owners should
maybe be doing this on a quarterly basis
looking at the clients ultimately the um
um what is it responding correctly and
there's an actual relationship there and
a sort of um
you're working with businesses that play
to your strengths as a recruiter and
these types of things so i guess that's
just a really valuable exercise to do
because as you said you can and as
you're talking about you can really get
lured into yeah we work for hsbc blah
blah all these and that's obviously a
good thing to say and it sounds great
but when you actually break it down okay
we sent these amount of cvs to hsbc but
send this amount of tvs to ex client
and this is what's happened and even
though so i guess you know like i guess
would you do you sort of actively look
at that now then and look at the clients
you're working with and are they is it a
two-way relationship and
yeah i think that's such a valuable
exercise to do because you can get
complacent can't you
yeah with um yeah big brands and kind of
the prestige of it all i think one of
the one of the things that changed it
for me was when obviously i i've been
working with this big bank and my third
vmware was that cos yeah or fourth fee
and at the time i just worked with the
hiring manager it was super slick
commercials were good and
you know i had a great relationship with
hr but there wasn't it was a very
seamless process you know two years on i
remember having to dial into a call
with the rpo this bank and ten other
rates he's one oh [ __ ] now weren't
allowed i had to do that for one of them
yeah clients it was horrible
it's like this is not what we're about
like yeah yeah it's a race to the bottom
and it just isn't going to work
and i just i just don't think you can do
this job in the right way if that is how
you do it
so that was a real that was a good
yeah no i think there's yeah so i think
people listening you should actually be
doing that i think that's such a great
exercise
um so how how was those difficult
decisions and that process then helped
you in where we are today which is
really challenging times
um obviously
um times where
it can change on a weekly basis day
basis so
how
so i guess i'm assuming that
has has all of that helped the i'm
assuming that you've got some really
good tight relationships with businesses
that you work with that obviously helps
in this time but how how have you been
impacted mate what's let's just set the
scene how how does your business look
today
it's been challenging
we've come off the back of our you know
really good year yeah that's really
helped you know yeah
we've we've repositioned ourselves you
know from a personal standpoint we've
been doing some really exciting co
searches for big for scale up businesses
awesome it's been really good fun um and
across the board sort of everyone in the
business has been doing really really
well and so
in a way
this crisis that we find ourselves in
we're coming into having had a really
positive unit which helps
it does help um
i think the culture we've
been fostering uh you know is one of
of kind of being self-sufficient being a
really close-knit team
supporting each other and creating an
environment where we all have a say
we're all able to share how we're
feeling and i think it's really
important for leaders to show some
vulnerability you know be honest when
you're not having the best time so
you're giving permission to your team to
to to sort of share how they're feeling
too and this is a scary time for a lot
of us and i think um what we've been
able to do is and it has impacted our
business absolutely
how many um
i think i've spoken to
so many recruitment businesses and
recruiters obviously so like how
percentage-wise in terms of live jobs
that have dropped what what's that look
like yeah probably 60 60 70 percent uh
yeah yeah good proportion and
the good thing is we've had some we've
had some roles that we we were close to
filling and that i think we'll still go
through which is helpful and we'll
hopefully buy this they're willing to
pay
i spoke to someone the other day where
they really negotiate turns on yeah yeah
because i had spoke to the chat the
other day who had just who started to
retain search
um
and yeah they turned around recently was
like yeah we're not we're not paying for
that we need to cut costs on that it's
just this [ __ ] situation to be in yeah
it is i think the good thing is we are
all in it together and this is a great
time i spent a lot of time talking to
friends who run other businesses and
yeah
there is a
we are all affected by this and i think
it's a great time to pull together i
think it's also a great time for the
industry to show what we're really about
and to add value value
ultimately clients will remember you for
how you react in this yeah
and so it's not the time to sell hard
it's it's done to be there supportive be
understanding and ultimately deliver for
the few mandates you have delivered make
sure you focus and deliver yeah focus
exactly i think what what we've done is
you know we're already
alice one of my team works four days a
week and we we already have one day a
week where we work from home so we've
been kind of set up that's good quite
working for a while and it'll be
interesting to see how this long-term
effect you know that's going to have a
huge impact isn't it i think we may end
up doing more more remote working um we
have daily stand-ups uh right at the
beginning of the day face-to-face
interaction keeping everyone updated and
yeah
what i've brought in i'm very conscious
i'm a very positive person but actually
sometimes i realize that um you know
that that's not always the you shouldn't
always be completely positive because
not everyone is going to feel that way
yeah we're trying to do is bring at the
beginning of each of those sessions give
everyone a chance to say how they're
feeling and actually
and we're we're doing weekly socials
we've done a couple of pub quizzes um
you know say a work version of never
have i ever you know things like that to
get to know each other and sending daily
pictures around just of what you're up
to and what you're doing just to kind of
keep everyone motivated and and positive
um
but ultimately it's about you know if
you've done the right things by your
business if you've empowered your team
if they're committed to your business
and if you're honest with him i think
we'll we'll get through this and i've
just been really really honest with the
guys about like these are the
cost-cutting things we're going to have
to do yeah
it's
for us we're in a strong position
financially but you know we also still
have to be careful of our cash flow sure
and so
you have to be honest and i've got them
involved in that and they've given their
own opinions you've over communicated
which i think is really key and stuff
like this i think it's really important
because it you know it takes away some
of that fear factor the unknown and that
this has all been hopefully how we run
the business anyway and you you want
them to feel like they they are you know
we have a private share bonus so i want
everyone to feel like they own a part of
the business it's not it's not just
employees that i tell them what to do
it's very much uh they buy into the
mission they really believe in it and
and in situations like this i think that
is really should come to the fore so i
think it's great opportunity for
organizations um but it's also you know
it's understanding is you know in terms
of what we've done or how the priorities
have shifted for for us it's been
firstly making sure is everyone okay
yeah yeah physically one other team you
know had a loss not too long ago and we
just said just take the week off you
know i think you have to be there for
people in these different yeah um
make sure they feel like they have a
voice and
i talked about delivering for clients
absolutely supporting the clients that
are no longer recruiting is there
anything else you can do yeah and then i
think it's a great great opportunity to
think creatively i think you know we've
we've expedited the launching of a new
proposition uh we're not going to be
selling it into clients anytime soon
because it's not the right time but it
gives us time to work on that and some
so innovation i think that that's
definitely what i've been that's where
my where my mind has gone yeah and
marketing you know yeah get hopefully
some there's budgets to get you in to
help people with their personal money
this is a great time to work on these
things and like you know i think whether
it's your personal your company brand
it's a chance to really show you add
value really show you different and also
ultimately like show what you're about
and i think yeah here's a great time and
i've been posting much more regularly
than i usually would um just to throw
some positivity out there because i
think we all need it what what is what
has the coronavirus taught you so far
do you think
i i i
think life is precious
i think i am
what i've realized is you know this has
given me a unique opportunity to be at
home and it's been my we've got a four
and a half year old towards uh an
incredibly supportive wife that's kind
of been through the ups and downs of
this journey yeah
and and i'm absolutely loving being here
and and and spending more time with them
and i think that amazon it will change
how i approach work going forward um
so that's been really important and then
the other one is just the importance of
resilience and being positive and
this is a time where leaders have to
have to step up yeah yeah and and be
there for that team have how how has it
been being a parent
doing this
[Music]
are you managing that yeah i mean my
wife runs her own business
and mainly from home say okay so she's
um she's adapted really well but she
also used to be an english teacher
saying oh wow i'm very lucky like
my daughter is having lessons here and
there and now i'm trying to help out
where i can we're going through daily
walks and you know having lunch together
and all that sort of stuff so i i must
admit we're lucky i know it's not the
same for everyone and i really feel for
for others who who are in different
situations but um yeah for us it's been
okay so far thank you
well um so just a quick one as we sort
of come to the end of this like what on
a day to day i'm just thinking because i
think
what what i plan on doing over the next
couple of um weeks is like
maybe you've sort of noticed the same
but i think there's there's loads of
sort of content right now
um aimed and focused on sort of
communicating to what people should be
doing if they've been furloughed um
which is obviously makes sense a lot of
people huge amount of people obviously
been furloughed and it will be difficult
and i think the sort of excellent advice
that i've heard and been given quite a
few times with the podcast i've done
stuff is very much remain match fit
personal development and these types of
things but i think that there hasn't
been much out there on sort of if you
have been kept on because you're someone
that's part of the nucleus of the
business and
they back you to weather their storm
and and crack on and power through
um like what what are you telling your
guys the that obviously are remaining
and whether in the storm right now with
you what what are you telling them to
focus on the day-to-day like real
practical stuff because i think
i've heard stories of people being told
to [ __ ] off when they're trying to do
business development and these types of
things but like what what sort of um
activities and priorities are you
telling yourself or your guys to focus
on that hopefully will give you the best
possible chance of having the outcomes
that you want
i i think one is
is you know this is a great time to hone
your craft yeah even back to basics back
to basics yeah it's um it's a great time
to check in with candidates i think
firstly it's got to come from a
you know we we ultimately and i'm sure a
lot of people listening really care
about the people they work with and yeah
this is a great time to check in with
everyone you've placed all the people
you've worked with see how they're doing
first yeah can you help can you assist
like and i think that first and foremost
is the most important thing
i think
it's the same for the clients checking
in you know they're not necessarily
going to be hiring but is there is there
another way you can add value or just
show some support so first and foremost
you've got to put profits out the other
window and just go right
just like be there because that you've
got to play the long game with this it's
not
everyone the kind of reactive short term
this recruiter is going to is going to
give themselves a bad reputation in this
climate if they they're just desperate
um and i think yeah i think you have to
be
the conversation i've been having my
clients is like you ha you have to be
empathetic you have to be a real human
if you're doing sales calls and just
actively phoning people because if
you're not if you are being tone deaf to
what's going on um you're going to write
people out the wrong way and it's going
to be remembered as you said and the
conversation i've been having is that if
you are generally having the intention
of hi james how's it going i know
obviously it's difficult period blah
blah blah there's anything i can do to
help blah blah blah you'd be you'd be
surprised how sometimes that can go well
actually you know what james um we want
to hire this person
do you know what i mean but i think yeah
you're totally right i think right now
and this is what i'm having to do myself
is like look all the people that are in
my pipeline that have been pulled and
these types of things this look it's
like look james let's just put aside
what we've been talking about
how are you what's been going on what
difficult decisions you've been known to
make how can i help can i help in the
short to medium term like and i think
being empathetic being a human
um when you're calling people being
proactive is 100 the right approach but
you'd be surprised how
much that would then return in potential
sales or whatever do you know what i
mean it will like i have no doubt it
will and it's not to say you can't
send cvs and be creative
if you've got the relationship with the
clients that you know and you're doing
it in the right way like then then it
should be absolutely fine but that's
that's ultimately what you can do you
know stick to the basics and you know
look after yourself and your own mental
health yeah make sure you're you know
i think recruitment owners have to be
realistic in this climate i'm not i've
said that because i'm not expecting the
same output i just think it's
unrealistic i think that's so important
because there'll be a lot of people that
maybe they're not being communicated
there might be obviously i'm sure
they've been communicated to but that
may not be that clear so if i'm
recruiting listen right now and i think
james my boss is like [ __ ] i've only
done like normally like in the normal
month i'd be here but i'm actually here
what's james thinking the
like i think that's so important that
hopefully a lot of people listening
right now their managers or leaders
don't expect the exact same outputs or
even maybe the same outputs but not the
same outcomes do you know what i mean
that's so important exactly and what you
want is your team to bring the best
version of themselves that they possibly
can and that's not going to be working
100 because their their mind is on other
things there's a lot of heightened
anxiety at the moment and so
and but but hopefully you know they're
they're getting the right levels of
support which will in turn you know show
that they're you know that you know
their boss believes in them and and they
can actually you know do what they can
to add as much value to the business as
possible and i think that's in this
climate that's really
about what you can do and continue to
develop you know develop everybody be
there keep this is a great time for lmd
and you know if you you can even if it
doesn't mean you have to go pay for it
you know just take some time out to
upscale your team and
and also from a social perspective keep
keep the positivity as high as you can
and make sure that you're um you know
it's not all work work work because you
know there is there's not as much work
out there so you might as well spend
time building
and getting to know each other better
yeah awesome um well look before i ask
you the the final question
what what are you excited about mate
what's what have you what sort of cool
things have you got planned or trying to
do
well yeah the next couple of weeks
like um you know we launched the podcast
last year and it's been a great learning
experience for me and and we've had some
some awesome interviews on that so we're
spending more time while there's less
work around uh to do a few more of those
um did our first webinar this week and
how'd that go yeah really well actually
really well um it was uh you know i
think
learnings from it and but um so far well
received and i think we can do more of
that sort of stuff and
so excite i'm excited to get back to
some sort of normality yeah excited for
the clients that we have and you know
getting back to supporting them um and
and you know ultimately getting the team
all back together in in person um but no
this this year for me is is exciting
because you know we're going to push
forward with the things that we've
launched in the last year we've got some
new exciting propositions we're keen to
kick off and and ultimately we want to
keep getting better and keep driving
that kind of high performance culture
that we aspire to have awesome
so final question james you can answer
it with a phrase a sentence a word
whatever comes to mind but if you could
communicate to
every single recruit out there they'd
listen they'd taken your advice and
implement it tomorrow
what would you say to the people
that's a tough one
as you can probably tell i like talking
for me
i think the most i think the most
important thing is to find your purpose
and find what motivates you uh like
ultimately for me it's it's providing
for my family that's what gets me out of
bed in the morning amazing that's what
makes me
hopefully a good leader and and you know
ultimately i think if you can find what
really inspires you and it might not be
recruitment it might be something else
but you can find something in what you
everything you do that can kind of get
you going and get you out of bed in the
morning i think that's really important
and the other thing is i think having a
growth mindset super important i think
you know learning from your mistakes
always trying to get better taking on
board feedback which if i'm honest
historically i wasn't always that good
at and i've had to work on and i think
you'll find this industry this you have
to be resilient you know
i think you're going to have loads of
knocks but if you can get back up
quicker from them and if you you can
learn from them then you will be that
much more successful and you know it
used to take me days and weeks to get
over the the things that happened and
now i kind of yeah maybe i'll go for a
little walk or put a hip-hop tune on and
yeah yeah there it is but do something
and then i'm like okay on to the next
guy yeah um so that
probably those two things are the most
important thing for me awesome
james it's been a pleasure it's been a
pleasure thank you thank you for having
me really appreciate it